Firms are real year he was acclaimed on the third Joe Wheeler year he was a claim to a wrong media Wilson runabout
clone in the Doris Prine fired though the screen lifted under the granite blocks out of the three small ships are just
come up and down to a from malaria and though they are his job was along with a document to place a relief.
It is of granite in the air in and out of earned in the error occurred courses.
However, earn her and Joe and I was a young a bit of a noun a Conservative man.
He quickly am to this place on the crane over a early in the morning
and commencing timely didn't leave at five o'clock p.m.
Did all his own firing of course throwing the car into the furnace business with a steam train
and the Hill to earlier that this involved using at the Square Mall shovel of cause
and found here along with the shovelling on the current of the furnace in the Jews.
So also uses several as a means of Rome, editing,
who himself under because of the lavatory reserve some considerable distance away,
hinder this was a very handy tool to scram our show will because is as well as lien using it for the firing of the
crane and are gems in an movements.
He also used to use it for four/ positive at all after it was sterilised record it is bit of a fight would be
sterilised with to whom her home in Flamborough resend sterilising her German invalid pantos Duane or used an" well,
apparently, yes I I I got over her clean. I was fairly well-known and under wheezed arid and drink.
Sometimes at the first last hotel in a criminal could Street do
and that other than that though a archive on the point of our anywhere homes under other as I was a single man.
Most of the time.
However, my work on the bridge there, but there at night times and power
and during those years I used to go to are a lot a lot of plays in Sydney.
Like her Rosemarie when it was available to you on her Majesty 's Pitt Street
and the will also remember seeing her in another play cruel lady be good at to the St James Theatre novelist the street
and also nineteen twenty seven.
At the opening of the Empire Theatre built of course by that well-known person Mister roof mail tender Sonny was unable
to first production there.
This is followed by the student prints that was in nineteen twenty seven square yesterday averaging you young Matt,
how much emotion nearer our role hotels Sydney R R I was so a customer Alvin Novo whatever dance hall to get a dinner
dance places near through into dances in the young in Pitt Street return,
most sir in this case it was a social studios are run by Professor Carrick are no Professor Kirk was about low
and because you are used to stay at the People's Palace and Pitt Street, Sydney,
but that on Sunday afternoons reached ago they dams and brother any dance planning at our status and yes,
you never dance places was so quails in or square in George Street, Sydney, and that was a very popular into place
and odour and logos across all the prices which it is most delamination under.
I just want to tell you about the Chip Caffey suggest to be available on George Street, North,
to eleven his unending about that, who held Sydney were hurt
or we will all want another all right I'll tell you about this cheap curfews in the roundabout per circular career
and George Street, North Sydney.
They were very very cheap firm the meals who could get twenty one meals for fifteen shillings in the course of runs out
of nine p per meal and they were three course meals
and they were very logical substantial meals because so you could eat as much bread and butter in July two as well
and are you, you would be issued with the purpose of small and home harbour crypt accomplished twenty one tickets
and at the time this to be quite a lot of seamen jumping off to ships in Sydney
and described her usual team to her because Lilly meals are so cheap that was quite easy.
Together these unemployed semen from overseas
or along the foreigners of course it will otherwise wouldn't have had in the food industry is quite easy to supply them.
These cheap tickets and because at that time because I was getting very good money at the Sydney Harbour Bridge
and it is no skin off my nose to help help these people as much focus on whether you live
when he worked on the beach earth for four years of my failures, unemployment,
they are I live about thirty feet away from the site of dollars of the so it is just out the front door into the Java
no reserve so I had no travelling time in those days
and video the finger of the term at the commencement of the every day. I have room doors point to number five.
It was really and I'm addicted to cut potentially as per week for this room and across the IR are Gallipoli.
So catches available in telling about circular Key goes to patronise some of them during the week
and then on Saturday and Sunday when there is no work because you know we had a forty four hour week
and worked only from Monday to Friday payout to leave her went to the class countries in the relevant percentage city
one that I can remember I was a Goldengate somewhere into Street, not far from kick from market Street, harnesses
and letters
and still have DMM are going to be in UK to the races are nothing like that unless you yes I used to go to the races of
nearly every Saturday under worse for very little result which switched racecourses litigated letter to get the pony
races altogether or status ESR Brindle apparently races and are richer and Gemmell Wednesday and Saturday, of course,
but are also frequent
and the main racecourses power Randwick Rosehill in Canterbury was a bookie in the arbiter where you are working,
it does point out well.
Learn that the only one that I knew I was so towards the latter part of the job relevant nineteen thirty one,
when no one of the foreman used to.
However,
run a game called Vic fires placed horses the low the prize for the fur roof are five pound window who have propose
shilling true for entry to this has to do under the foreman down their on-the-job here are so before in the of just
mentioned about to go to get her very steep.
It was search of the Hillary Newton, hinder here is my friend goes on the months as point side
and before he became a foreman who via who has a concrete mixer driver at terminal six.
Four about four failure for authority is an error.
The other from an unknown adult points I deserve a middle-aged man
or more overland literary Lindy at the track Chloe at the time of my employment in the dollars.
Two you are very popular from here believes in getting fed modern fair days work out of the workers.
I think this has bit on London's object to that over,
now across that fitted the online has given that the stonemasons are again on your view,
but a number of their names unless you see your I can remove the stone motions they are more or less forever.
Therefore, of a period that I was there so I became familiar with and Larissa Angus Cruickshank,
the young Scotsman also Tom like,
crime under her reserve also pipe major Sydney Highland Society banned for many years in Sydney also another man.
No Mister Dunlop.
I just can't figure this first name
and also were to project Baxter under Jack was an interesting culture the pro from one hundred
and bar that these faces of course each other labourer under John Baxter is so labour was so named David Baxter,
a young fella but no relation to him and learn
and her were the documents name was to release under also Scotsman under a very fearless so how died
when he wants to study dust stonemasons gains that our dog on a labourer understand that yesterday over the reserve.
The two people,
assisting the stonemason Caesar did block sustainability large Monday to fiercely blocks of stone locals have two holes
brought into the top of on an angle under the dip and eighty paraphernalia was called hard chained dogs
and these same first two p put into the into these are holes and under London analysts owned
and that was hooked onto value of look of the claim under the stones are listed in the developing the fashion you were
given time in incidence earn about term Doctor Bradfield yes yes numbers are living in dollars.
Oh George should not sometimes of hours of this called in those days.
I remember one solitary morning I was working at the intersection of the following George Street under that attractive
to turn round of the key under Doctor Butterfield happened to be at home with a rating is the term that morning
and under the logo on the term layer to stop is fair for me to world is going,
which was only about two minutes walk anyway,
but the adductor blood filled produced his gold the interview did eBay fear of the owner didn't pro from me.
Oh,
and under the new myth that well Joe you hear he gargling elbows near the theatre that that's collected afloat the prototype
and some gold in the conduct of the doctor clutches are go apart which is very good.
I felt that it is just that some of your own doctor, Brazil, says to come down the offer of a Saturday morning he was
or is on his own organisation to hear sector used to access the Mornington sentiment Bogarde ducked the doctor are used
to seeing going down there and it turned liquid over himself,
but he was never accompanied by anybody says that adjusting the hard during the week because it would be accompanied by
inspectors and live like that. He was to go to check up on things.
Several people tell me arcs middle of the other side
when they were pines give access to come down at six o'clock in the minds of the first,
the first poor if rely what are you on about skew broach. I was in the first one of dollars.
On the south-eastern side under of course it's a massive reinforced steel in there as well
and the concrete was a special mixture of cause it to.
I remember it was completely dark and we heard the lamps her to enable us to see what we were packing high up.
This is one of the learn the bearings concreting in the bearings in a decision single, poor to that.
Yes, it was a single pool it, but as I say it is a tremendous amount of the reinforcement steel in it
and no video her if because of a very awkward to get the become critically in in and around in every corner
and technical training. but Of course it was done under or so earlier we hinder low and electric light.
I am Leeds high see you were inside the bearing packing with concrete from the inside your earth wonderfully in Soho to
live so I understand now you're packing back in the concrete)
deep underneath the berry to make sure it is lit eight run right inside the BST will contain heart placed this is a
more incidents like that your number about it and of
and awkward places we had packed concrete her year you refer all we were awkward places under that concern the main
floor as it was called witches ( hundred and fifty figure someone nearer was in fact level
and the are the bands instructs on that very awkward and I can remember I was sent down as an private,
I think I can say that I was the home.
I think I can say without further application posted just telling the story looked I was looked upon with the gun
packer well begun as you know is sometimes referred to in sharing is so profound so my dear gun shearer relentlessly
person would do more or less the lesser post
and hard evidence over two I do so without further are reluctant to think
and I can number being sent down in one of these beams
and the fighting BDO product from the amount was about the movement of the displacement would be about six seats
greater under part about ten feet to a mouse also of room for Pope concrete reinforced the steel rods under our actual
number had great difficulty difficulty getting down between the the or how to go because the computer is being more
or less drawn down on top of me and I'm I was equipped with firm as are our seals confirm the unknown skin.
None hirsute
and also I remember the parrot have so Wester on my head to work future stock from the road being pulled the local me
but that was one of the most awkward jobs.
I have the fitness to little late, they are I know I got a load of the singer correctly because and
when it was stripped of the snow at the call of bony earth stuff you know everything out of the could smooth finish
hunting people realised today exactly what there went into the year the packing of concrete in those days for the
hernia vibration in our system.
It is more of a matter of routine, as long as the mixture is right of the child while it was over
and as you can see it was all done by hand under it to work with this backing tool,
which had a blade of about four inches and know it in no words
and it was all have to be done laboratory by home tell media.
Do you have a history with a concrete mixing games at all I only had done our own about the collection.
I had with them.
Yes, I neural of across personally and by name and I
when we got up to a certain heart on the pylons of the telephone installed
and we used to render window of manifesto became became a fairly good estimate of how much concrete would be needed in
such and such a place
and O2 ran down to the to the mix to video mixer driver until it how much rent would require very required.
This is when we were mostly finishing off the job tuna member the size of the mixes were in those days.
Her were the concrete mixers were all near a rollover of our ruler are now.
I just can't tell you the exact lie understand that there were one cubic yard machines will reluctantly)
would be reluctantly regard because a registrant Australia's of the bucket skip
but back although stuttering I do remember now that it had held two yards.
So they would mix one yard at a time and enough foreign one, and lectured
and put it into the skip in the trainer would holiday but would be correct at an incredible.
In other the size of those of those pylons, the amount of concrete
and all mixed in one cubic yard machines fed by hand incredible that would be right years earlier,
mechanically concrete trade would be one out at a time and because it was only via metal or aggregate usage
and that a map concrete was a costly broken stuff from the room till me how you were employed from nineteen twenty
seventh nineteen thirty two and you'll were constantly employed on packing concrete
and yes I would say that I was constantly from on one side as well so there will be another
and again is whether a concrete gangs tour altogether are no longer on nineteen twenty nine are a mate of mine below
move the blowpipe Charlie Charlie Thomas was/ no digger from the first floor.
He was my co- packer and then from nineteen twenty nine on we went over to Wilson 's point
and Charlie alone did most of the packing is that how many gangs whether therefore owner of the packing concrete.
I will they would be one else is wrong message.
Side and were the printer or a home in anything well who are of a mechanic concrete on the ground.
The estimates of driver.
The two men are filling rickshaws with blue metal are not blue metal
but malaria mental than those one-man filling rickshaw with sand
and has an additional man to cater for the name of petty crime his job only was to put the cement in who lived in the
study for a limited time at cloud Dawes point for many years and who is a very humorous man who was Australian,
an Irish Australian and here talus minimally stories and emphatic at local Court on stories about that is,
those were workloads in the hip hip.
He was a coat of the study are to our artillery will follow the story about a amount to live a story of the roundabouts
of roundabout September nineteen twenty seven. I took the day off.
I asked foreman Mister simpler for a day or from lucid,
yes we wanted for us on a return boot recession in connection with the second of study Mark notice in America so in the
game, information and
but I think I was one of the twenty five thousand men had much through Sydney streets that die from the domain down
Martin Place of George Street, and we finished up in Belmont Park, but never our station have up till then it out.
I understand this was the biggest demonstration in Sydney and will also in nineteen twenty seven,
the return of the story about tonight back on that a lot of people I know about second Vanzetti
or to what this is about their birth saccharin rooms only richer Italian columnists who were wrongfully convicted in
America, power, there was great to outcry all over the world about time these people around.
Of course it so well known.
Now they were trained under on charges of robbery bank robbery in America after they were to run militant commonness
and for this reason they paid the penalty and as I say in Sydney
but though there was a great demonstration among Mister frustration of workmen parading through the streets of Sydney
you had another yarn as you can tell us about term hurled Irishman who is still good stories in her home.
This is a chip the moment, Paddy crying.
It was an Irish Australian under delivered,
though not far from me at the door 's point during their four failures of those working there
and here is a very humorous man tell a lot of stories Australian jokes
and firm over as an injunction against aborigines, are quite a lot
but don't wonder they are in a relevant nineteen twenty seven of them chap came under home two dollars.
Side Burnley is very well dressed and unknown,
it is limit amongst the workers of this must be an expert on the tunnels under at that time there will be cables are
being threaded through the media tunnels to the whole rack Fiona Pender, however,
the next day this are well dressed individual started work as a labourer and he proved to be an Englishman
and done anyway here are so very well spoken and done here that we the Monday before the twenty period.
The day before burned very will just put to did look as though my bill over British riders
and learn anyway here he was given a job are working hard.
I will follow on the radio on the envelope behind a concrete mixer under his job was to travel in some of the metal
that was used for the concrete
and anyway the sporadic trying his job was only two within the cement into into their own sales
and make the concrete mixer that's all it have to do and, of course, in those days,
so the cement was seven was parcelled up in no jute bags and it was a very dusty job under very dirty joke to factor.
However, the Sir Patrick for only under your job of keeping count of the amount of concrete was sent up and down here.
I remember via the sermon harassing clever from an era said they like to live possible to set set a record of a hundred
and fifty batches firm that match was how much our batch would be a two yards of concrete that is to mix is full.
Yes, it would be two mixes for you suddenly ride and anyway the so petty crime, he kept the score window.
He had litre with various unrelated to Bridge board with holes in it under EU two years a match to tour the pudding
media being that the number of batches that left McPherson
and under his cunning fellow theories to keep the score actually about ten behind product was actually window
and error in the Sir Deyo media at matches, pointing at a hundred and fifty under
or pressure to recruit from the accountant and a can of Israel are closer to rural splendour no absolutely.
He whosoever firm score of one hundred and fifty move.
He said the hundred and fifty bloody both survey Linda Pattison nurse tried to show the hundred
and fifty purchase under the Count said the home worth more bloody money. He said Linda Addy said the already said.
It's not so much the money is the owner and under the counter said the bloody honour is a merger of likeness
and Paddy said to Rowley said Cos it is not so much the on the money said, as there is with Fiona
when you're writing to your paroled mother in England,
he said your mail to tell her the friend in Australia you knocked up a biggest school with a shovel
and Jack Hobbs did with his bat you think you do this to me get this straight about the concrete mixing teams are a
better researching.
I would understand that they would be numbers of concrete mixing teams
and numbers of the list of concrete teams packing that you say that there was only one team, he sighed.
Yes, upset and Senator one teammates RBF.
There are the that the men were placed in the position under that was a first, actress
or are unemployed was placing his men in intelligently that each mounts into earn a narrow PMO is exactly what was
required of England,
a jock proceeded quite smoothly should we go over that again exactly what each each mandate first can you explain
exactly what is mandate of the concrete mixer.
Yes there were two men Philip filling these barrows which bananas the vendor first to enter the two men filling lose a
number of one man filling a rickshaw with sand under as a restricted to the China leader of a hopper of the concrete
mixer the limit and that this other man called Paddy kind heated,
he kept the required amount of cement into the harmony is that so far relate would be heard to on the middle one on the
sound one on me and cement and also to Mexico
and the women of the year the cement went up top harmony in your going up the Arab versus another chap
and myself that arm but there was out at the firm place of the either at the placement from a concrete.
There is also a document and he had a whistle and he made signals to the cone drivers are spotting boring,
so there was one Mexico and you to that built the whole of the pylon on the south side, plus a bit on the north side.
That's true you so that was to two teams of men literally build those gigantic pylons I would say that is correct to
that actually incredible. I was under the impression that there were dozens teams all over the place.
It seems to me to be absolutely incredible and REM actually receive your
when I first started in twenty seven Larousse three concrete papers
but term runabout throughout nineteen twenty eight should say so there was only another chap myself
and causes corresponding are going movements is put inside and ran into an multiplied side
and one concrete in their world.
In nineteen twenty nine earlier as you know Leo
and for the city side order of sprint side of the pilot was well advanced and the Braeside rivers are well behind Sara,
along with a known Charlie my other made my mode with malicious damage and virtually to know,
is the actual use properly was left Thomas her record and blowpipe Charlie and them. He was my mate.
They are right structure of the entire passing under that extra 's and Nelsons.
Two as well because lived to come backwards and forwards are on the lunch and hence under Vista,
early Archana Bridge sometime as not many people could look at those pylons of the I felt that the view you scroll the
thing was really are. I think we traverse an amount applied in a work undone.
We made sure that everything
and leaves timber was taken away stripping them removed everything looked her gritting finished in fiscal matters does
something is utterly amazing to me to think whether arm of any other young women.
It is one other thing we'll on the packing of the concrete down into the tunnels for the cable 's in the cable tunnels,
yes there are so down.
Learn the talents also and across the erosion of its period out of solid block
and Justin King explain the that the cable tunnels under the purpose of
and the actual building of them from scratch that will actually be nineteen twenty seven,
the tunnels had just about that now become excavated and I didn't have any part of that,
but I did homerun her work down now under the Carpenters are six carpenters employed across on on the DOS.
Side her right throughout the failures that I was there to further the tunnels were line refer corrugated iron under
like on the SCUBA and the rules fixed of course in place by the Carpenters and across all work.
We don caused by electric loan to value could well imagine under that though once one C Alderson curved earning
corrugated iron was put in place that it was also backed up by concrete
and oh yes I did a lot of that went down as well.
How did you get in to pack behind the in the corrugated art in those tunnels are of whole will you see her.
It is only the concrete was only lifted up and say height so large and depths,
but I should say of four to five feet so leave her that would be left that payout lift of say five feet would be a
fraud that would be left on an hourly, carpenters would turn put up moron corrugated iron
and so forth up to the top of the top up to the top of the plan
and set would follow the concrete up on that one is it there is just explained to me,
something which I find difficult to comprehend. You explained.
First, these the cement mixing team which is a team of five are on this.
Two of your packing so that soon seven plus oh six carpenters servers as sex in the survey.
Section as it S thirteen years of well I forgot to mention all so that when the concrete rivers forward
and reverse scrip are to be pushed along the river crank repeated that also two logos employed pushing the skip along,
but so that would make another two workers employed actually employed on
or that including carbon is a sunny fifteen to perform the people who will build the formwork mixed concrete put it
around and finally painted on the whole of the other pylons is fifteen aside according to what you sent it as well.
In addition to that, there would be three men are bending and placing no reinforced bar.
I still only eighteen thirty eighteen men are sided are building the violence in this plus there is the year of the
stonemasons had how many of those are relevant to one stonemason on each pilot and he had a logo
and also a document so that three aside so that sixty six further men.
They are so that takes into twenty four to twenty four men, including this stonemasons built those pylons right up,
including the further carpet is the stonemasons concreting gangsters are what I would think that would be a first class
in particular was twenty four managed so this is forty eight for the two cold rolled from river would be other firm
labourers employed from time to time under no no each person who do a lot of tales judging their about all return to
the much more note on the predominantly more and employed until they are under your problems were to be washed down
and am about to late nineteen twenty one to early thirties, as it is incredible to me.
I can they certainly got their money/ treatment they were yes I think so,
use the cross with Doctor height money undercutting after fifty feet
and noted increased quota quota deal under human thought your money was are available.
Roll the think the most money I ever got reserve run about thirteen to fourteen thousand dollars included that of over
the term at the same time after about fourteen pounder.
None of the main people train drivers you know only receive fourteen pounds ten
and of course can concurred with that term bridging no New York to help Cambridge Sir Sydney got the Sydney Harbour
Bridge built very cheaply because some figures under and the boilermakers
and no on the New York Bridge were getting at the equivalent of sixteen pounds and nine.
Australian money will overhear constantly value the young rate was about nine pounds.
It seems to me you that that there were very few men involved in actually liberal in the Bridge.
The way I have read it arm is about a hundred and fifty people about were building the arch and if it's as you say,
which must be that the pylons were built by about another fifty people that only two hundred building the whole of the
bridge and pylons and the rest of the employees were involved. Therefore, in the fabrication.
The workshops
and the quarry earlier here of several bureaux eyed under most figures about the amendment to the employed immediately
around the country admits in England who are only rare about another one that was so rare mansion unnumbered Bouverie
on the child.
We will be known as indictment but you didn't leave the ground and that was one of them was occupied
and omitted Leo was jailed dealer under England sought staking under Saudi media Granite is derived from malaria
and bury another man.
I think that going that would mean it would be fifty two test at the twenty six aside here are highly I will think that
rebuke will be much see your recover your carpet the price that's tough that's very,
very much less than I thought I had never never occurred to me they would be as little as that.
Yes,
I think that the looking back on some of the papers that I have her year that would be about the number of names that
would do the coding of our people will be employed because that I have someone told papers here that the trip to from
nineteen twenty nine and on during that time and similar as soon her own timber workers strike
and also Newcastle crosses, see our coalminers were on strike and twenty nine
and wish to take up the levies for there to assist these people are out on strike Lyndon and oh,
I still have some focus of the names of the men that you are dilated under.
I think that would be a roundabout the total number of people
and that I can remember collecting money out for the strikers what exactly is until to do with as papers,
even in the union all I will either of the kept her in the house, a term like some of my rather tattered
and under faded now because the term of the distiller still in the drawn well I'll am saying is that I think it's
important that they get preserved or at least competent but into into some format in the Mitchell library
or call with your union assemble Uni library. Yes, I think I still have them, and in the draw.
They are not have to make sure I'm still pinching the home puzzled about in that year the figure still have a think
about much Mister Jack McKay on one of the very,
very few men who built those gigantic islands of the Sydney Harbour Bridge given a member of the inspection of the
registered member, who did the job and and how was her views known.
I can remember Leo, one of the inspectors so infected. He was an engineer matter. Mister Butler and chest.
He was Public Works resident engineer for the year for the substructure are years ago who he was in attendance at a
fair bit of the time that of crossing under another man under him were who was there with us all the time window.
He saw that this is the stuff was placed in and the mixture was a bit of a year.
Up the quality under all that serving written his name was Mister Bill Anderson is a the year immediately under the one
that was in immediate term,
her vicinity of over the two of us all the time to deal have two order to their ever order that the concrete,
be removed from being run consistency and no, not that I can recall I think everything was up, up to a specification
and its effect was there all the time you seen stricter said yes that C and Rio were– trying to think of inspector.
Yet he was there all the time is that different from any other job, even on.
I will use the notes on city buildings had been employed on in other days of the Snowdonia inspector there that I can
remember
or clerk of works are I don't remember going on some of the big jobs lead that have a cloak works her Richter have any
work that guided must never supervise their exit by the perhaps the contractors for modern all-round panic
and cross over.
Have you did you ever see a bad mix is a concrete on the city were at yes I have done that are not seen no where cement
was home to correct amount of cement wasn't put into the mixture. Never or you can think of her new home home.
The most recent roses firm the cane keynote factory to Fairmont in Sydney. It was badly next the cement was well.
I remember seeing some of the mixer under who it was so skimped on our lesson admission of it.
It is far less meant that I think should have been well thank you Ginsburg
and will you tell us about the years disputes between the builders labourers
and the AWI with a the bridges of Victoria on earth are in nineteen twenty six,
I was working for Armstrong would worth over a on a bridge over the bar on the roof and south Geelong
and the discharge was covered by their Australian workers union,
though during margin to around the job already been going twelve months and I got the job are under.
I was on for the last twelve months of its third towards its completion during that time the federal secretary of the
builders labourers Federation in Melbourne came down to Geelong
and client proclaim the work as belonging to the bill 's local union home this General Secretary Lew the little
consideration was an amendment may repair system of. He was a militant and done.
He had no hesitation in foreign anything about stopping the job of south Geelong and as another factor.
Everybody left the job labourers, carpenters, electricians, even people putting the gas our mains across two over two,
South Geelong from the city side to the job home were out of work.
They were out on strike for a fortnight during the food I received/ payroll Arizona a single man I received two pounds
per week strike pay node man got a little more however Percy Smiths are to advise us of any bridge building in
Australia after that would come under the jurisdiction of the builders labourers Federation in nineteen twenty seven,
when I came to Sydney.
I was already a financial member of the builders labourers union and
when I presented this ticket to the AWT represented a representative of a tourist point at the Harbour Bridge.
I was told us that it was no good that I'll have to join the oh W her at the moment at that moment I consider that I
was entitled to work at the Harbour Bridge with this ticket that I had covering me as a bill of global that Lara.
Oh, I was denied this,
actually the representative of the KW that I was speaking to another showed the ticket to a after it became a great
friend of mine,
but at the moment he was inclined to two that are heard to pick a fight with me are because I initially objected to
during the O. W.
They were little as about the relief work in that the passion of Jill builder were on the building of the Reg and yes,
Mister yes sir, I will tell you about Theo relentlessly just a straight out safe
and the relief work of the relief work,
rather we were getting our runabout nineteen thirty four consisted over tunnelling
and the non- from the Sydney around about the one about our Chatswood and places like that
and I am the water board had done suspended operations from about nineteen hundred
and twenty nine were narrow appears about her making these tunnels so for around seven.
Origin no later annunciation suburbs under and about nineteen twenty oh thirty four by I.
I was one of several other people who were offered to reach worker in every five weeks
and that this averaged out of twenty seven and six p per week and I was very distant.
This was just abstract of this work are relief work was served to got two weeks of every five that whisperer are a
married man with one thousand years yesterday, so twenty seven six p per week averaged out over five weeks address.
So my wife and the one one child and that there is consisted of very laboratories were
but that I can save the data me over the people who were called up per of Theo Dahl registered under were employed in
the yard are a tunnel where I was wrong